i told michael wilbon years ago i said
if you start this part in the
interruption show you're going to be
stuck with kornheiser for 20 years
well we're on 19 years mike can you make
it another year with kornheiser
oh we can go longer than that by the way
i steve fuller i actually knew
that answer steve fuller quarterbacked
the bears
and he actually won a playoff game um
because jim mcmahon was hurt in 1984 the
year before the
field super team and the shuffle and all
that and the year before they won
he's in the shuffle video steve fuller
yeah
yeah he beat uh i think he was i'm
pretty sure he was the starting
quarterback beat the redskins crush the
redskins and they were defending nfc
champions
in washington i'm sorry i'm not supposed
to say that anymore the washington
football team yes of course
uh but yeah i think i pretty much fuller
was number four was in the video and won
that game
growing up in chicago did you go as an
athlete
uh on halloween
wow damn no i don't think i ever did i
did that when it's boring stuff like
scarecrows and skeletons
i don't think i ever like got you know
like yeah you mean i got dressed up as
gayle sayers or ernie banks or something
yeah
you know i must have done it once i but
you know what
you know this you just couldn't get a
uniform
anywhere back then when we were kids
right now you had a hat
like it was a big deal if you got a
batting helmet you went on and went to a
game on batting helmet day
but we didn't have uniforms and jerseys
and stuff didn't we
i don't remember that they weren't into
marketing like that
back then and you would get you could
get those plastic batting helmets that
they would you know
strongly suggest you don't use this in a
real game
i don't think i think i think scarecrow
and skeleton was as good as it got for
me
all right let me start with tony la
russa going to the white sox
and aj hinch to the tigers i was
surprised that the
negative reaction was more towards
larussa coming
back to the white sox than aj hinch
going to the tigers
why is that because we have a generation
divide we have a generation gap you know
you look you and i grew up in what was a
writ called the originally the original
generation
gap right between us and our our our
sort of slightly post-world war ii
parents that was supposed to be the big
generation gap
that's nothing that is nothing we came
around
ultimately to you know i would say to my
father
is all you want to do listen to nat king
cole and frank sinatra
and then in in 30 years i listened to
that game called
frank sinatra right and then my parents
said oh yeah i'll try some marvin gal i
have
i have some more marvin gaye i'll have
some more that is not happening
that is not happening now we have a
generation gap which is
frightening and these these i'm sure
these
they're or i'm i'm told they're people
in the organization
not to mention players who just look at
larussa as some
fossil and he did they don't want
anybody
who's not their age looking at instagram
all day we have a
really serious
uncrossable making of a word now
not spannable generation gap in the
world and and this higher
that's why i think we're we're hearing
so much negativity about larussa
well a couple of things came to mind
when i saw the hire
i i was like of all the people available
why tony larussa and why does tony want
to come back and manage
now at his age that's a young team
that's a playoff team
and then you also had this oh he's not
going to embrace analytics and i go
wait a minute that's what you're
bothered by that tony won't embrace
analytics we just railed on kevin cash
with
tampa embracing analytics now we want to
make sure that tony la russa is going to
embrace the analytics i'm thinking
tony was embracing analytics before i
think
any other manager was yeah
to a degree and that's the problem with
today's baseball
you know you have so many people who
just want to be they don't want to
embrace they want to they want somebody
to be slaveously devoted to it
they'd rather have a mathematician they
want all the business guys they want
guys who
study and favor probability they don't
give a damn about having a manager
who understands you know
just the human element human condition
the fact that a guy might and his wife
might be having a baby and he's going
through something
for two or three weeks at home they
don't want no no just straight numbers
we don't want to have you actually
manage people i thought baseball took a
massive step back tonight a couple
nights ago
massive step back i thought it was a bad
night for sport
that we had a pitcher removed while he
was
trying to become sandy koufaxer bob
gibson for his team i thought it was
awful i asked johnny bench about that
you know the role that the catcher can
play
because that's who i want to hear from
yes the catcher is going to say
skip they're not even close on these
pitches or they're catching up to him
his you know his curveball doesn't have
bite you know that fastball
it's getting up a little bit now if you
tell me that
right that's what i want to hear not
this guy when he gets into
third time around in the lineup he gets
roughed up
i i would have just left him in for
mookie bets
i i wouldn't see how he got through that
because he struck him out twice
but dan they don't give a damn about
what the catcher has to say
they're just studying cards just think
about the okay
baseball's the worst the most offensive
at it right now
but think about pro football you have
coaches
they're not thinking about the logic at
the mo in the moment going for two
and what their team's morale is and what
the opposition no they got a card
they're looking at statistical
probability you know i mean
you know i just it's but this is where
pitching staffs are
headed which i don't like it but
you know you're just you're looking at
you know what what this is going to be
is this just a a phase no
no this is where this is no this is why
so many people are up in arms about
larussa it's not a phase if it's a phase
dan this one
you and i are not going to be on the
other side of the end of the phase
yeah but i think we're looking at i
think we're looking at this is the way
the sport has gone
and i i can't anticipate what trend
might replace it
20 years from now and i get it i don't
want to spend 300 million dollars on
garrett cole
if i can spend seven million dollars a
piece on
ten relievers who throw 100 miles an
hour and that's what their job is going
to be
i mean we're not going to see a contract
like garrett coles again
in baseball because you don't need a
starting pitcher you might
see those contracts for hitters but
you're not going to see it for
a starting pitcher unless it's the
yankees or
look unless somebody's a wild card and
they so out of 30 teams how many are
going to
not be everybody has embraced in
analytics how many are not going to be
slavishly devoted who's going to be a
thinker
who's going to be an outlier i mean that
there'll be somebody
but the dodgers even with that payroll
they took andrew friedman from tampa so
they took that philosophy and attached
it to a big payroll
but the fact that we went the dodgers
are this is a bullpen game they have two
starters
they have two starters who matter i know
but just the fact that you go this is a
world series we always got caught up in
those pitching matchups like
who's starting game two uh the bullpen
is
that's what i mean
is what i should have been saying yeah
only have two i mean who's gone into
who's gone into a postseason being fine
with that
well not having david price two because
he opted out
he would have he's michael wilbon from
pardon the interruption
and then you have the situation with
justin turner and baseball investigating
the dodgers i think baseball should
investigate baseball first mike
because how does this happen that
it's inconclusive and then it is
conclusive and then you take him out now
where does he go
and then why he's not cordoned off
why are we allowing results when a game
starts
should we be allowing for test results
they've been around everybody
and then you had what happened after the
game as well which i understand
your teammates are fine with you i'm not
fine with justin turner being around
the wives or girlfriends because they
did not sign up for this
the players the players did but
we had no positives for 58 days or
whatever it was
and you have women i think there was one
uh
woman who was uh was pregnant pregnant
yeah
yeah and and they're out there and
everybody's you know intermingling and i
you know i had a real problem with
baseball and then
justin turner was extremely selfish he
was
and i'm trying to figure out if i i
might hold the dodgers more accountable
because they knew dan
once and i agree with you about why are
you having results brought down the
middle of the game well they couldn't
have gotten that done at 6 58
before the eastern before the teams took
the field
but i mean the dodgers have to have some
accountability i mean a large
a lot of accountability at least once i
presume it was baseball
told the dodgers yeah at that point
obviously there's got to be more
protocols if you use
if you need more protocols well
apparently you do but i i don't know the
dodgers in turner
and i wonder where this is going i mean
they may investigate this is going to be
i asked tony this yesterday it's going
to be like the nhl where
you know if a hit results in a broken
jaw the guy's got to be out for two or
three weeks or as long as he's at but if
there's no consequences
you know he could be back the next night
what happens to turner who particularly
is a free agent
is it based on consequences suffered by
others yeah because of his actions i i i
don't know that i want to see that but
this is hard
i i think you you even brought up like a
sliding scale
you know sometimes our reaction or the
punishment has to fit the crime well
what's the crime
if nobody tests positive here is he fine
is his fine not as large
uh or if somebody happens to test
positive
and he might have said hey i'm a free
agent
i may never get to this point again i'm
i may not be with the dodgers next year
i'm going out and i'm going to sit there
in the photo and i'm going to be part of
history
he just didn't realize what part of
history he's going to be involved in
and there could be you know you hope you
hope just in terms of health and safety
that this peter's out but but it might
not
the nba it what is it the nba talking
about christmas
and if they start on christmas the
amount of money
i guess the rough estimate is around a
half a billion dollars
yeah if not they wait another month
what do you do if there's no fan what if
does this come down to if lebron says
i'm spending christmas at home this year
i'm not playing
until january well
you know it could come down to him
saying that dan because obviously
we know the influence he has but i'm
told yesterday
last night that they're they're quite a
few players
now how are the star players all aligned
here
look if the star players are in lockstep
and they just say we're not dude this is
crazy we're not doing this and here's
why
i i i right now if you tell me over
under december 22nd i'm gonna say beyond
i i don't see it um and it's not just
because of lebron but again
it's the the word influencer in
basketball starts with lebron james
and i don't blame him now i understand
though that there are obligations this
is this is being driven by
my bosses and the bosses at turner i
mean this is being driven by them i mean
and i understand that everybody's every
no one wants to lose hundreds of
millions of dollars
but what about the rank and five players
who outnumber the stars
what 10-1 in the nba what about the
rank-and-file players for whom
you know i think it's 550 000
on average so what about the average
nba player who has that salary yeah
because they're splitting the 500
million
yes with the owners yes 250 million
dollars and
i think i figured out it's about 560
thousand dollars a piece on average
are those guys going to be in lockstep
yeah
well by the way what are you up to these
days
now nothing i got no there's no sports
at night
i have nothing no you know
it's um are you watching anything good
not yet so i the week the week after the
nba playoffs maybe two weeks out now
i just sort of you know pushed around
and tried to act like a father and help
a 12 year old with homework that i don't
understand
but that's going to end quickly so it's
like you're on your own kid
so i'm waiting like are we going to get
scripted dramas back i'm not a reality
tv person i don't care about reality tv
are we going to get scripted dramas i
know this is us was on are we going to
get like all my shows back
am i going to have that am i going to be
forced to read
um you know this is going damn this goes
back to when
you and i were young in high school and
there
wasn't sports every night that we could
see
and we had to do we had to be engaged by
other things yes there was sports
but not every night there was monday
night football and then you'd have to
skip out until
saturday right yeah we have stuff
tuesday through friday
well that's why i think the invention of
big monday
on espn established espn sports center
because you had big names and then you
had the big 12 and big
uh the big east and it led into
sportscenter and
back then you didn't know what the end
result was or you didn't see the
highlight
and you have a built-in audience i i
think that played a large part in being
able to carry those games and they went
right into sportscenter
and then sportscenter sort of took off
and became a thing
but when we were growing up you got
three minutes local
and then you got howard cosell on monday
night who might
show a highlight of your team that's
right
that was it you were done you know you
were done it was it was like a
referendum on whether your team was
wrong
if howard got in there you were in that
three minutes you got like 30 seconds of
walter payton goose stepping in it
for me but but you know so yeah we got
we got all this time and i
i get why look remember a year ago
there was all this talk about all the
atlanta owner one of the atlanta owners
said we should ship the season and end
it in the summer
how quickly has that been knocked down
right
i mean the nba can't wait to get out
there we have
the nhl hasn't weighed in yet
loudly and the nhl season would be going
on they'd have been
they've been three weeks in by now yeah
so what are we gonna have
in that way we don't have college
basketball for a while
uh until january so it's it's whip man i
mean this is not
it's not early pandemic dearth of sports
but it feels pretty empty
it feels like we're going to be stuck in
this for at least another year
as far as affecting sports when you can
play how long you can play
what are the safety protocols we're
finding this out with the big ten the
big ten it feels like
is really fragile right now
because of what happened with wisconsin
does this happen so
how long are they out how many games do
they miss that affects
all these other schools and and the pac
12 hasn't even started yet mike
and the fact look i mean the whole just
i mean california
and the fragile nature yeah of the state
and the number of teams they've got what
for
um i know they haven't and so the big
ten
situation is fascinating because they
decided not to build in time
you know he said this is what we're
going to do and remember dan
those wisconsin quarterbacks have to sit
if those positives were confirmed 21
days this ain't like the acc
well they're trying to change it though
mike they're trying to say that they
didn't have enough
data for the 21 days therefore they want
to
kind of respond to 14 or something i i i
think
it feels like an amendment's happening
[Laughter]
an addendum is happening soon here right
now
yeah yeah so this whole college football
season you're just scared
i didn't know until very late last night
um you want to know what i'm watching
i'm watching the law in order to reruns
i'm going to get through the whole 450
again
so i'm watching law and order reruns
last night on sundance i i can tell you
off the top of my head which which
knights are on which networks
and there's something just said even
though there were no games my son
said dad aren't you going to check
sportscenter before you
and i said no they're no games he goes
why don't you just check you always talk
about
news and i said there's no news click
trevor lawrence yeah and i was like oh
my gosh
you know what is this gonna what is this
really gonna mean now
uh somehow he'll be available i think
for the notre dame game
just somehow somehow yeah hey
uh great to talk to you congrats again
for 19 years putting up with tony thanks
for joining us
well thank you and thanks you were there
at the beginning like you said you i
i remember at one point i said dan
should i be doing this i know
he said i'm sorry has your brain died
while we're sitting here talking i know
i said it you got your own show
like they're giving you a show and tony
said the same thing he goes
they want us to just get our big fat
heads on tv and
yap and he goes exact quote
does anybody care and i go they're
giving you a show
tony hey
at least golf we owe you something so
thank you let me co-host one time
i love that you think i have to twist
our arms for that
yeah i think the mothership i think to
you're fine with the mothership now i
would have to clear it with them
okay so wouldn't it be great if i i just
showed up one day and i didn't i didn't
connect with anybody at the mothership
would i last the whole half hour oh yeah
okay
oh yeah we'd love that just want to make
sure all right come on you're on to
something
i'm ready i'm let's just plant the seed
one day mr tony
is on vacation and i just show up i'll
be in his attic i'll just show up
you mike thanks dan appreciate it that's
michael wilbon